This guy's probably fought hundreds of
thousands of other super beings on the
other planets he's destroyed right and
we have to assume he's won I don't care
how many demons he's fought and how many
hells he's never fought us, not us united
Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this is
going to be my video about what happened with
the justice league snyder cut trailer the official
version of the trailer on all of warner brothers
and dc's channels you may have noticed that you
cannot watch it on any of their channels right
now it's completely gone there's a whole bunch
of stuff happening behind the scenes i'll explain
what's going on there's been a lot of theories
floating around some of them are correct some
of them are not correct so i'll explain what's up
if you're new to the channel be sure to subscribe
to get all the videos there's a bunch of really
cool stuff coming up i'll just number these as
we go along to stay organized but starting with
the big stuff you may have noticed if you try
to go to all the official pages of the official
youtube channels for warner brothers in dc to try
and watch the justice league snyder cut trailer
you can't youtube facebook twitter instagram you
either can't find the trailer or it won't play
back if you find it in an embed you just get this
error message that they effectively took it down
this just happened a couple days ago there was no
announcement made warner brothers dc didn't have
anything to say about it they just quietly clicked
a couple buttons behind the scenes in poof south
park style it's gone uh what it's gone it's all
gone what's all going poof in the last day or so
zack snyder himself hasn't commented on it because
he himself is the person that cut that trailer
you may remember earlier this summer when he
was hyping people up just teasing out little bits
of footage like here i'm working on something to
show you in a little while most of the time
movie marketing departments create trailers
directors don't create trailers but sometimes
people like zack snyder want to be involved
in that process but as of me posting this video
he's actually in the middle of shooting all that
additional photography with the cast of justice
league shooting the new scenes for the movie
they just started that a couple days ago so
the timing on this is a little bit weird and
when fans started freaking out on social media
pounding the official hbo max accounts for answers
this has been their only official response
thank you for your interest the snyder cut
of justice league will still be available in 2021
at this time no additional details are available
and that's it so you can actually see the fans
screaming in their comments tell me why what's
going on naturally there are all kinds of theories
about why this happened that hbo help account
wasn't lying though the snyder cut is still coming
out next year as planned that hasn't changed
this business with the trailer having to come down
has nothing to do with that but the trailer before
it was removed was the most watched video on hbo's
channel in one of their most important pieces of
marketing for the movie could you imagine
them removing all the batman trailers from
the internet just a couple months before robert
pattinson and matt reeves batman movie came out
it would be the dumbest thing you could
possibly do from a marketing perspective
what movie was that a batman movie no we don't
know what you're talking about then it just shows
up in theaters and makes half the money that it
was supposed to because it wasn't getting any
promotion some people thought they pulled the
trailer down because of the behind the scenes
changes that are happening at warner brothers
recently both warner brothers and disney just
completely reorganized their corporate structure
in the past year to be more focused on streaming
hbo max and disney plus are basically the futures
of those companies so they obviously want to build
those brands up so while their biggest ip new
movie projects new big budget tv projects are
all being developed exclusively to go to those
streaming sites they're still going to release
movies in theaters it's just that now most
of their attention is on the streaming stuff
and less on the theatrical stuff the fact that
movie theaters have been shut down for most of
2020 has accelerated a lot of those plans you may
have noticed too there's a warner max logo on the
justice league snyder cut trailer that was the
production label inside warner brothers that they
were using to produce the snyder cut and as of
october warner max no longer exists they got rid
of it during that reorganization and created
a new streaming focused film division that's
going to release the movies so when they release a
brand new justice league snyder cut trailer it'll
have the new film divisions logo on it but that's
not the reason why they had to remove the trailer
the actual reason was confirmed a little while
later it took a while to figure out what was
actually going on there were enough journalists
pounding all their contacts within the company
and it turns out that warner brothers in dc
had to remove the trailer because of a music
copyright issue doesn't that feel familiar there
is no youtube creator on the platform that has not
had at least one of their videos claimed because
of some pop music that was in it so this basically
means that whoever cut the trailer zack snyder and
whoever he was working with used the leonard cohen
song hallelujah didn't get permission or pay
enough money to the record label that owns it
don't blame zack snyder for this usually
he works with a team of people so it might
have been somebody on that team that didn't
completely work everything out behind the scenes
usually when dc marvel pretty much every studio
releases their movie trailers and they have pop
songs in them they have to pay crazy money
depending on what the song is some songs
more popular they have to pay more money obviously
remember way back when the original suicide squad
movie came out and everyone was clowning on it
because they crammed so many pop songs into it at
the last minute the music budget for that movie
was in the millions of dollars even if they're
only using a song in a short trailer they still
have to pay the full amount to license the music
a giant dumb truck of money and on top of that
artists and labels can say no you're not allowed
to use this song they have to approve its usage in
whatever your trailer or your movie is before you
release it so they post the justice league snyder
cut trailer at dc fandom and has the leonard cohen
song hallelujah throughout the entire video is
pretty much the entire video gets tens of millions
of views everyone goes crazy everyone's happy
and usually none of this is an issue because when
studios license pop songs for their trailers or
their movies they usually go to the record labels
that they own themselves because if you're gonna
have to pay a ton of money who better to pay that
money to than yourself but the thing about leonard
cohen in the hallelujah song is that sony music
owns the rights to all of his songs so they
probably either felt like warner brothers didn't
pay enough money to use the song or they never
asked permission in the first place and threatened
to sue them for an even bigger dump truck of money
than they would have originally had to pay so it
just seems like warner brothers has voluntarily
removed all the trailers from their sites of
official sites while they work it out with sony
and once they fix that they'll put the trailer
back up on all their official pages so don't worry
about that they'll pay all that extra money that
they have to pay apologize and everything will
be fine when they release the next justice league
snyder cut trailer just don't be surprised
if there is no leonard cohen song in it and
i wouldn't be surprised that that next one doesn't
drop before the end of december i don't think that
the snyder cut itself was going to be released
till at least the spring next year maybe early
summer so we probably see some more footage before
the end of this year i know a lot of you are also
asking wait a minute the full justice league
snyder cut trailer is still all over youtube
on a bunch of other sites people's channels why
is it on those channels and only warner brothers
took the official versions down that's just
because sony the rights holders know that you
me all the regular people that are posting or
reposting or using this trailer in their review
and commentary videos at least trying to use it
in some sort of fair use don't have crazy deep
pockets so sony is really just going after the
big fish here they know that warner brothers has
billions of dollars and can pay them whatever they
want it's a really silly problem to have but stuff
like this if you can believe it happens all the
time it's just that usually it gets worked out
before people post their movie trailers for
the first time so you never hear about it
but right now most of the scenes zack snyder is
filming with the cast of the justice league for
the snyder cut are a combination of what i would
call inserts and smaller scenes intended to bridge
together bigger scenes maybe a little bit of
additional inserts for some of the action scenes
but the amount of time that they're filming isn't
quite enough to film a whole new big action scene
this is all the new ben affleck batman and jared
leto joker scenes that they announced last week
that's right jared leto's joker is coming back
to film new scenes he was never supposed to be in
zack snyder's original version of justice league
movies both of them because originally there were
going to be two movies the report on that is
that it's believed they're using him for new
flashback scenes for when joker and harley quinn
killed the dick grayson robin to pay off the whole
subplot that they set up during batman v superman
because i believe originally the intention was as
they would address that finally in ben affleck's
version of the batman movie when he was still
making it before matt reeves and robert pattinson
came on for their version of the batman movie
the only big justice league actors that aren't
coming back to film brand new scenes are henry
cavill superman because he's currently busy
filming the witcher season 2 he's been posting
from behind the scenes so toss all the coins ezra
miller's flash and jason momoa's aquaman are also
not listed on the cast coming back but that just
means that zack snyder already has all the footage
of them that he needs interestingly enough though
talking about aquaman he is bringing back amber
heard's mira for some new scenes for the atlanta
stuff because the snyder cut is gonna be over
four hours long there's basically giant subplots
and arcs for all the different characters that
get way more into their backstories especially
the newer characters which at the time aquaman
was one of the newer characters we didn't know
a lot about but part of the reason why they're
adding all the batman joker stuff reportedly
is just because they're never going to get a
chance to cover that in the next 10 years in what
would be a ben affleck batman movie just because
they're so focused on the robert pattinson batman
movie and introducing the michael keaton batman
so the belief now is that zack snyder is using
the justice league snyder cut to resolve all
the things that he eventually intended to pay off
in future movies after justice league one and two
but once they do start releasing all that stuff
obviously i'll be doing easter egg videos for all
that but leave all your dc video requests in the
comments below or if you have any big questions
that i didn't address during this video i've got
a bunch more marvel and dc videos i'll be posting
this week there's also the mandalorian season 2
episode 2 video that i'll be posting on friday
while you wait for everything click here for
my full mandalorian season 2 episode 1 video
and click here to find out about how the studio
was trying to get people to make a superman man
of steel 2 movie thank you so much for watching
everyone stay safe i'll see you guys tonight!